today on the matt welsh show the mayor
of new york city is the latest
high-profile democrat to come out in
favor of drag queens at school we've
talked about how it's harmful to kids to
involve them in drag events but today i
want to discuss how drag attacks and
demeans womanhood also the cdc issues
guidance for how to have sex while
infected with monkey pox if that's
something you want to do nancy pelosi
again proclaims herself a devout
catholic while shilling for abortion a
hollywood actress explains why she chose
surrogacy and her explanation perfectly
illustrates the problems with surrogacy
in our daily cancellation a dog food
company encourages millennials to become
quote pet parents instead of real
parents we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt walsh
[Music]
well we know that we are
we assume probably just days away from
roe v wade uh becoming a thing of the
past and you may think that that means
the fight is coming to an end over
abortion but abortion legislation
returning to the states just means that
the real battle is really only just
beginning there is no group in america
better position than 40 days for life to
help fight
that battle just as they've been
fighting the battle now for decades 40
days for life has 1 million volunteers
throughout the country holding peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities
you may be surprised to hear that their
largest presence is actually in the
states where they're needed the most
that would be the country's blue states
with california being their biggest
state their vigils have closed many
abortion facilities in america and
nearly half of those facilities were in
liberal states where abortion will
continue to remain legal after the fall
of roe from san francisco to chicago to
seattle
which are hardly pro-life areas
obviously volunteers have guided
abortion workers to have a change of
heart and quit their jobs so as this
issue gets out of dc 40 days for life is
effectively changing hearts and minds in
the grassroots of the pro-abortion
movement check out their location their
locations their podcasts and their new
book what to say when the complete new
guide to discussing abortion at
40daysforlife.com
there was a period of time which lasted
about 45 seconds it turns out when it
seemed that the new mayor of new york
city eric adams might be a relatively
normal decent rational
competent human being but that was all
an illusion of course those sorts of
people simply cannot be elected in the
modern democrat party
they are non-viable candidates
particularly in a place like new york so
after impressing us during the campaign
by saying some provocative things
arguing for example that criminals
should actually go to prison sometimes
you know things like that really
controversial it's no surprise that
adams has long since surrendered to
leftist insanity in that vein
adams tweeted yesterday afternoon this
is what he tweeted he said
uh drag storytellers and the libraries
and schools that support them are
advancing a love of diversity personal
expression and literacy that is core to
what our city embraces at a time when
our lgbtq plus communities are under
increased attack across this country we
must use our education system to educate
the goal is not only for our children to
be academically smart but also
emotionally intelligent
to be absolutely clear here eric adams
the mayor of america's largest city is
arguing that we must have cross-dressing
men in school
for the sake of diversity personal
expression emotional intelligence and
literacy
indeed our children will be illiterate
if they're not taught to read by men in
dresses
that's why no child in america has ever
learned to read up until this point none
of us know how to read we're all
illiterate
you know i don't know if you knew that
because we all suffered from a severe
lack of drag queens growing up after all
nobody ever even considered putting drag
queens in school up until about 12
minutes ago it was never discussed it
was never imagined it was never
considered an option it was not a debate
anybody was having when i was in school
nobody was debating this
nobody was saying you know should we
maybe we should include some drag queens
in this whole thing this whole deal here
nobody said that but now in the last 12
minutes the left has declared that it is
not only an acceptable option but that
it is in fact necessary it is crucial to
a child's development that he be
frequently exposed to men with
cross-dressing fetishes
that is the actual official position of
the democrat party at this point it's
not just being advanced far out on the
fringes by groomers and pedophiles it's
now being advanced in the mainstream
though still by groomers and pedophiles
notice again
the flight path of progressivism okay it
always follows the same course for first
they you know whenever something comes
up
some new uh brand of degeneracy
first they deny that it's happening at
all in this case they denied that
anybody wanted kids to be around drag
queens and then
they admit that it's happening but they
say it's it's rare and it's not really a
big deal and then they admit that it's
happening all over the place but they
argue that actually it's good and now
for the final stage they say that the
thing they used to say isn't happening
at all
is actually happening and happening a
lot and should happen and needs to
happen and should be mandatory
this evolution from not happening to
mandatory doesn't take very long at all
sometimes the plant will grow to full
bloom in the space of a week or even a
day
meanwhile a video is going viral today
of uh of one drag queen out in the drag
wilderness crying out against this
madness here this unnamed drag queen
from a video i think this is about a
year ago
scolds parents who bring their kids to
drag events the events that he performs
at
and confirms that drag shows are
inherently sexual both on stage and
behind the scenes listen
what what in the hell has a drag queen
ever done
to make you have so much respect for
them and admire them so much
other than put on makeup and and jump on
the floor and ride around and do sexual
things on stage
i have absolutely no idea why
you would want that to influence your
child
would you want a stripper or a porn star
to influence your child
it makes no sense at all
a drag queen performs in a nightclub for
adults
there is a lot of filth that goes on a
lot of sexual stuff that goes on
and backstage there's a lot of nudity
sex and drugs
okay so i don't think that this is a
an avenue you would want your child to
explore
yeah that's uh
that's a good point you know it's good
to have at least one person in the drag
world
confirm what should be obvious but
really we don't need them to confirm it
you need to only watch a few seconds of
footage to understand what's going on
for example uh the latest clip posted by
libs of tick tock shows a drag event
attended by at least one very young
child and featuring a half-naked man
with fake rubber breasts dancing around
while the audience hands him
dollar bills um
here's that
[Music]
feeling like a woman
and that was that that appeared to be
the child's
grandmother
that the child was sitting on on her
grandmother's lap
my grandmother if she had
encountered an event like this she would
have called an exorcist she would have
called the police and an exorcist
your grandmother
what chance does that poor kid have you
have multiple generations of degenerate
groomers
raising you
my god
now we've already said plenty about how
this affects kids who are exposed to it
how this is all part of the less
overarching effort to corrupt and
sexualize the youngest generation we'll
say plenty more about that in the future
i'm sure as the groomers continue to
ramp up their war against our nation's
children i give it less than two years
at this point
until elected democrats are explicitly
arguing in favor of decriminalizing
pedophilia
um they're already arguing for that in
effect in certain ways but um it'll be
explicit in the next two years they're
not going to call it pedophilia of
course they'll use the a different term
like minor attracted person or else
probably they'll come up with something
new but
we're we are very close
to that threshold being officially
crossed and we inch closer every day
that's why the battle to protect our
children's souls and minds and innocence
is central
in the overall culture war but what i
want to focus on today for a few moments
at least is something else not entirely
unrelated
because while all of this represents a
war on children it also represents a war
on womanhood
as i've argued in the past drag is
female blackface that's what it is drag
shows are essentially modern day
minstrel shows where men dress as
hyper-sexualized cartoon versions of
women and they dance around for the
vulgar amusement of the crowd
now put to the side just for a second
the most shocking and disgusting aspect
of the video that i just played namely
the fact that a toddler was in
attendance
even if there was no child there what
does it say about drag and about the
left generally that it's considered
wholesome and worthwhile entertainment
to watch a man in a skimpy skirt with
absurd amounts of makeup bouncing around
the room with enormous fake rubber
breasts
if there's any entertainment value and
such a bizarre spectacle though i don't
see any value in it at all entertainment
or otherwise
it would be in the i guess macabre humor
of watching a man make an
over-sexualized mockery of womanhood
the potential comparisons are obvious
here imagine the same sort of scene
except that it's a a white man in an
indian headdress
dancing and whooping around while
onlookers laugh and clap just imagine
that
or a white man in blackface or a white
woman in a fake afro lip-syncing a
whitney houston song
in fact that doesn't even need to be
done for laughs we've seen white people
get cancelled simply for wearing
dreadlocks
or opening chinese food restaurants
no intent to mock or satirize in that
case and still it's somehow considered
dehumanizing and degrading to the groups
of people who've allegedly had their
identities appropriated quote unquote
but in the case of drag the whole point
of the exercise
is for men to appropriate womanhood
that's what people are paying to see
that's what groomers are taking their
children to see femininity turned into a
circus act womanhood as a carnival
sideshow
now there's no surprise womanhood is
commandeered objectified parodied in
many ways in our culture and um and
quite often this happens the left has
never met a form of female appropriation
that they don't want to celebrate
the dirty little secret about that side
the left
is that they hate women and they
actually hate women even more than they
hate men
i've realized and they hate men quite a
bit
so this is saying something
now they call masculinity toxic but they
actually idolize it they're jealous of
it they're envious
that's why they they you know they want
all these female action heroes they want
females in the military they want us to
celebrate women who become uh tough
corporate bosses and ceos and so forth
but femininity they have no use for at
all it's a thing to be performed and
laughed and gawked at
they chop the breasts off of girls and
put rubber breasts on grown men people
are like potato head dolls to them swap
one part for another it's all the same
as far as they're concerned they see
human beings in general in this light
but their assault on womanhood takes
oftentimes i think
a different kind of form from their
assault on manhood
womanhood is made into a fetish
or a joke or a performance
often all three at once
that's what drag is
womanhood as fetish joke and performance
womanhood appropriated degraded
made into something ridiculous and ugly
and this i think is a point that we need
to start making
more often
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well fear of out-of-control inflation is
hammering the stock market the s p 500
is having its worst start to the year
since world war ii so
not only are your savings worth less you
now have less of it on top of it insult
to injury now so now might be a good
time though uh for you to diversify into
gold the most stable asset in the
history of the world and birch gold is
the company i trust to help you convert
an ira or 401k into an ira in gold and
silver not only will birch gold help you
fortify your savings with precious
metals they'll also help you do all of
this in a tax sheltered account so all
you got to do if you want to learn more
is text walsh to 98 98 98 to get started
amazon stock is down 37 in the first
half of the year tesla's down 40
and cryptos have been slammed plus many
fear the hawkish moves by the fed could
stall the economy so what's your plan
text walsh to 98 98 98 and get your free
no obligation info kit on gold from
birch gold they are the precious metals
professionals they're the ones that i
trust and you should trust too so again
text walsh to 98 98 98 and secure your
savings now all right the daily mail
reports that the cdc has issued bizarre
guidance telling americans infected with
monkey pox
to have sex by masturbating at least six
feet away from their partner
among other recommendations now this is
guidance from the cdc
it says anyone who has the disease must
not have sex but for those who ignore
the advice the agency has published a
list
of the do's and don'ts under the bed
sheets
among its tips was also to have sex
while still fully clothed to ensure all
rashes are covered and even to avoid
kissing
other advice was to wash your hands wash
hands fetish gear and clothing
immediately afterwards and even to
consider having sex virtually such as
over the phone this is okay so we have
uh from the cdc they published this
chart here which you can see
and then they give all the options with
help with helpful illustrations in case
you weren't sure what that would look
like
um and then they say yup try virtual sex
uh masturbate six feet apart this is the
the centers for disease control and
prevention are giving advice on on you
know masturbation
um
make sure to wash afterwards they say
avoid kissing wear clothing
during the sexual act
and cover your rashes so
uh
this is uh yeah that's a good way to put
somebody in the mood i guess is just say
hey you know i'm covered in monkey pox
lesions so um
yeah we can still have sex i'll just
let's just keep our clothes on
is what the cdc is suggesting
how much
you know
the self-control that you would have to
lack
that you can't even abstain while you
are covered in monkey pox
rashes you have zero self-control and
but this is also
how the government sees us
that's how the cdc sees us
they see us as like um
as animals we might as well be monkeys
to them with the monkey pucks
they see us as animals that cannot be
expected because obviously
the the the right advice here that you
shouldn't even need to tell anybody is
that if you have monk if you have
something called monkey pox
like i don't even need to know anything
about monkey pox you tell me that
someone has monkey pox i already know
yeah you should probably should not be
having sexual relations with anybody
until this issue is cleared up and after
it's cleared up maybe wait another like
month or something
um but
rather than just say
okay you have monkey pox you're covered
in rashes and legions your skin is
breaking out into hives and everything
rather than just say don't don't have
sex at
all they they've just decided that like
people aren't capable of that so instead
here are some ways to do it that will
mitigate your risk
slightly
if you can somehow find someone who will
have sex with you while you're covered
in monkey pox legions
they really do this is um
we're living in a brave new world
and the government sees us as these uh
animals driven entirely by compulsion
[Music]
who have to be controlled and and
muzzled as we saw for two years with the
masks
it cannot be cannot be uh trusted or
expected to to exercise any kind of
self-control or any sort of judgment
whatsoever
this is how we're seeing
uh and the really and the the the even
sadder part of that is that many people
in fact live down to that impression
that the government has of them
because it is a self it is a
self-perpetuating
uh prophecy in a lot of ways and
intentionally so
all right let's move to this nancy
pelosi was asked a very good question
doesn't happen very often from the media
but
i suspect the person who asked this
question i don't know who it is
i'm sure that information is available
but i suspect this was not somebody in
corporate media
but she was asked
does she agree as a devout catholic she
claims does she agree with the pope
all popes actually but specifically the
current pope and the and pope john paul
ii
that abortion is murder does she agree
with that as a quote unquote devout
catholic let's see what she says
john paul ii said an evangelion vitae
that abortion is murder and pope francis
told the pontifical academy for life
that abortion is truly murder do you
agree with pope francis and pope john
paul ii that abortion is murder
what i agree on is that whatever i
believe or agree with the popes on is
not necessarily what public policy
should be in the united states as people
make their own judgments honor their own
responsibilities
and uh
attend to the needs of their families
my speaker actually is as far as the
abortion case is concerned there has
been a number of attacks on
uh on churches on uh crisis pregnancy
centers republicans are
going under democrats for not saying
anything and they're saying that veteran
is contributing to these attacks and
it's first trading well let me just say
this
a woman has a right to choose to live up
to her responsibility is up for her
her
doctor her family her husband her her
significant other and her god
this
of politicizing all of this i think
is something uniquely american and not
right
other countries
ireland italy
mexico have had legislative initiatives
to expand the woman's right
to choose very catholic countries i'm a
very catholic person and i believe in
every woman's right to make her own
decisions
very catholic she's very catholic
um and and you know you notice she
doesn't she doesn't actually say that
she disagrees with the pope on this and
to be clear by the way
um
we talk about do you agree with the pope
about abortion being murder
it's not just
from a catholic perspective if you're
actually a catholic it's not just that
the popes have
you know given their own personal
opinion about the fact that abortion is
murder this is the official teaching of
the catholic church
um
and it's a it's it's a teaching that
you cannot
reject
without rejecting the church itself
because as i've tried to explain if you
reject
a fundamental moral teaching of the
church
then you're saying that the church is
wrong about fundamental moral facts of
life
then you're rejecting the moral
authority of the church if you reject
the moral authority of the church then
why in what sense are you catholic
not in any sense at all
and this is the same by the way for any
religion
if you claim to be a part of the of a
certain religion but then you say that
you disagree with the fundamental
teachings of that religion then by
definition you are not of that religion
that might be uh
a mask you like to wear it might be a
banner you like to march under it might
be something that you like to perform in
front of a crowd for political reasons
but it's not a faith that you actually
hold
within yourself
what i would like to hear someone ask
nancy pelosi is rather than do you do
agree or disagree with the popes on this
how about uh
here's the here's maybe the way that i
would phrase it and there's really no
way to phrase the question that will
stop someone from nancy like nancy
pelosi from just
wiggling her way out of it and dancing
around it because she has no integrity
or anything like that so when you're
talking to somebody with no integrity
there's really there's really no way
um it's like wrestling a giant slug or
something there's no way to get your
hands around the argument because it's
nothing they say means anything and they
can contradict themselves
themselves as you know within the same
sentence but the question i would ask is
do you believe that god
recognizes
uh a woman's right
to kill her unborn child i think that's
probably how i would phrase it
because you could say all you want well
women have that right
and you can get around it by claiming
that technically
according to the law as it's written
right now they have quote the legal
right
as in it's something that the law
as invented by human beings says that
they're allowed to do
but is this a another way of putting it
is this a natural is this a part of
natural law is this a natural
human right
to kill your unborn child
is that something that god would
recognize
another another way phrasing question
when god creates
a human being
and puts that human being
in the in the womb of a mother
does god want that human being to be
born
or did he create the human being in the
womb of his mother
uh with the intention and hope that that
the child would be dismembered and
thrown into a dumpster
what do you think about that
again no way to phrase the question that
will actually make them say anything
honest but uh that is that is one way of
putting it all right this is from the
washington times it says republican
senators are heading off any attempts by
their colleagues to include language
requiring women to register for the
draft in the annual defense policy bill
in a late in a letter uh wednesday to
senate armed services committee chairman
jack reed 11 lawmakers led by senator
josh hawley warned of solid opposition
to force american women to register for
the military draft
it says women have served in and
alongside the armed forces since our
nation's founding lawmakers wrote while
american men are required to register
for the military draft and fight if
needed these requirements have never
been
applied to american women where they
have fought they have done so freely
this approach has served our nation well
and it retains broad bipartisan support
and a bunch of republicans signed the
letter um
just trying to head off at the pass any
any attempt to put to you know
officially require women to sign up for
the draft now
you know this is one
where you have to be careful because
there there are people on the right
and this this seems to me just
anecdotally to be to be a
a position on the right that's gaining
some steam and becoming kind of popular
and that position is that hey okay yeah
just
sign women up for the draft too because
we're told that men and women are the
same this all the feminist stuff girl
power
and uh hey this is what you guys say
feminists that everyone is exactly the
same exactly equal there are no
differences women can do everything that
men can do
um all of that well then you should have
the exact same responsibilities and
under that
way of thinking there's no reason at all
to uh
exempt women from the draft
so it's kind of a hey you you made your
bed now you have to lay in it approach
so there are a lot of people on the
right that are saying that
that's not my view for a few reasons
number one is that um yeah you could say
that to feminists and to the left and
all of that
but uh my own daughter is not a feminist
and she's not on the left
and god willing if i raise her right she
never will be
so this is not now if there was a law
saying that uh left-wing feminists so
men and left-wing feminists are eligible
for the draft then maybe we have
something to talk about but that's not
what we're talking about
so you're talking about punishing all
women and all of our daughters in order
to what send a message to feminists
um
and many of whom by the way the you know
people on the left left-wing feminists
especially people you know the the
feminists and on academia and you're
coming up with all these theories and
everything they're not gonna be they're
not gonna be
actually drafted into any war
as we know the draft you know this this
actually only affects in reality poor
people and middle-class people
so a lot of the uh feminists and people
on the left
who you're trying to
stick it to here
it's not actually gonna affect them
it's your own children your own
daughters
they're gonna have to pay the price
so that's my first problem with that and
why i could never support
drafting women and then the other reason
too is that um even if i didn't have
daughters of my own
we just cannot be a society we can't be
a country we can't be a civilization
that drafts our daughters into combat
that sends our daughters against their
will to go fight our wars and die that's
just
once we become that
and if we all accept it then that's just
the end basically
that's um
that's the end of our civilization as we
know we've just kind of given up we've
thrown up the white flag completely
we get to the point if we all just agree
that yeah sure whatever just send our
daughters off the fight
even if the draft has never actually
enacted
which i suspect eventually it will be
but even it never is the fact that we
would all be willing to do that
if we declare our willingness then that
to me is just an act of total
civilizational surrender
that i could never be a party to
all right let's see what else we got
here uh this is from the daily beast
that says the office actor rayne wilson
who obviously played dwight schrute came
a bit too close to embodying his
inflammatory tv character dwight schrute
on wednesday when he tweeted a poor
attempt at a joke about transgender
people
he tweeted quote t.i.l you can no longer
say nursing or breastfeeding mother you
have to say chest feeding person
just fyi that was the tweet
which i guess is supposed to be it's not
even a joke that's just a
that's just true that's like what the
left is trying to do they're trying to
to uh supplant breastfeeding with chest
feeding
so he tweeted this and then but then he
tweeted an apology i think we have the
do we have the actual tweet from him um
he tweeted apology said yesterday i
tweeted a mean crack about breastfeeding
versus chest feeding after speaking with
some tren trans friends and educated
educating myself a bit more i want to
apologize for the tweet it was adding to
misinformation and meanness i'm sorry
so of course he immediately came again
what he originally said was not even a
joke or a crack about trans people
he was pointing out
that chest feeding has become the new pc
term of art which is true
but then he had to apologize for that
because he was educated by his trans
friends
educated about what exactly what did
they what did they teach you is what i
want to know
and the thing about this whole
breastfeeding versus chest feeding thing
is that that it doesn't even make sense
okay even on even on the the left-wing
premise here it doesn't make sense
it's exactly like the latinx latinx
well we need to have la tinx because
it's gender neutral hispanic is already
gender neutral
you could say latin and that's gender
neutral
so along with all the other problems of
latinx the first problem is that it's
not by your own
premise it's not necessary
and it's the same thing here chest and
breast these are synonyms
essentially
like
men have breasts there's a reason why
men can get breast cancer it's rare but
men can actually get breast cancer it's
rare because they have less breast
tissue
but men have breasts
and the words are basically used
interchangeably
so this it's a distinction actually
without a difference in the first place
so when we're told by the left that uh
well we need to say chest feeding
instead of breastfeeding because it's
more inclusive that doesn't make any
sense
the two words are synonymous
now
what the left will say in response to
that is well if they're the same then
why can't you just change it
if it's if it means the same thing
anyway then why not just say chest
feeding instead of breastfeeding
no no that's not once again
i don't have to provide that explanation
to you
no it's more like why should we change
it
if it's basically a distinction without
a difference
and the change doesn't make any sense i
don't have to explain to you why we
shouldn't change it we've been using the
term breastfeeding forever everybody
knows what it is
you're the one suggesting the change you
have to explain it it's not up to me
you're proposing the change so that's
something that you have to defend
why is this necessary
but of course you can't defend it
the only defense is that well it makes
trans people feel better why does it
make them feel better number one
um
so we talk about breastfeeding that make
that makes them feel sad why
and then the second question is why
should i care that much in the first
place
why should we have to go through this
great effort
to change a term that everybody has been
using forever and it has caused no
problems for anybody and now we've got
to change it because a couple trans
people had their feelings hurt
explain that to me
um
let's see
we've got now
rand paul versus dr fauci this is round
like 50 i think um it's kind of a long
clip we'll play some of this though
here's rand paul trying to
investigate the financial incentives in
the vaccine push let's listen to some of
this
another question for you the nih
continues to refuse to voluntarily
divulge the names of scientists who
receive royalties and from which
companies
over the period of time from 2010 to
2016
27 000 royalty payments were paid to
1800
nih employees we know that not because
you told us but because we forced you to
tell us through the freedom of
information act
over
193 million dollars was given to these
18 employees 1800 employees
can you tell me that you have not
received a royalty from any entity that
you ever oversaw the distribution of
money in research grants
um well first of all let's talk about
roy that's the question no that's the
question have you ever overseen it have
you ever received a royalty payment from
a company that you later oversaw money
going to that company
you know i don't know as a fact but i
doubt it well well here's the thing is
why don't you let us know why don't you
reveal how much you've gotten and from
what entities the nih refuses look we
ask them we ask them the nih we asked
them whether or not who got it and how
much they refused to tell us they sent
it redacted here's what i want to know
it's not just about
just to give you the spoiler he doesn't
answer the question of course he says
that well it's that's not information we
have to provide and everything else
now i see these i i really i continue to
appreciate rand paul's efforts here
um and one of the reasons why i'd like
to see him
jump into the race in 2024 i hope he
does
and you also have to keep in mind that
you know rand paul was doing this
it's a little bit less politically risky
now
but he was doing this calling uh
fauci to account back when fauci was
you know the great the great saint and
on the left he still is but there was a
time when he was like celebrated across
the spectrum in that way
and uh rand paul was still doing this a
lot of credit for that
but every time i see videos like this
i'm also slightly frustrated
because i because it feels kind of
futile and hopeless
um
to expose all of the corruption and then
okay fine we expose it
you can embarrass him in these public
hearings which is which is great
but what needs to happen is people need
to be arrested there need to be actual
legal consequences
okay and that's another thing in 2024.
that's what i want to hear from
republicans running for office
uh they're going to find out they're
going to get to the bottom of all the
corruption related to covet
related to the people who shut down the
country for two years and all the damage
that they caused knowingly caused
and they're going to find those people
they're going to arrest them that's
that's what i want to hear all right one
other thing here this is from the daily
wire says dexter new blood actress jamie
chung admitted to choosing to have
children via surrogacy because she
feared getting pregnant could ruin her
hollywood career
the 39 year old real world san diego
alum
made her motivation clear during an
interview with today chung recently
welcomed twin boys along with her
husband brian greenberg
couple's been married since 2015.
she says i was terrified of becoming
pregnant i was terrified of putting my
life on hold for two plus years
in my industry it feels like you're
easily forgotten if you don't work
within the next month or your last of
your last job things are so quickly
paced in what we do so it's a compromise
that we made together as a couple
she continued i think there's a little
bit of shame it's still not a very
common thing and we weren't ready for
judgment we really just did it to
protect ourselves we announced things
when we were ready to
uh and then she responds to some of the
critics she says people probably think
oh she's so vain she didn't want to get
pregnant and it's much more complicated
than that for me personally and i'll
leave it at this
it's like
i worked my ass off my entire life to
get where i am i don't want to lose
opportunities
i don't want to be resentful
that's her response to the charge that
she's vain and not doing yourself a lot
of favors
no no not vain i just didn't want to
lose any opportunities
with the inconvenience of carrying my
own children in my
womb and i didn't want to be resentful
resentful of uh who your children
seems to be what she's saying that if
she if she had
decided to you know get pregnant the
old-fashioned way by actually being
pregnant she would have resented her
children for depriving her of
opportunities
you could see perfectly illustrated here
the problem with surrogacy in general
um there are many problems
it starts with the commodification of
human life
the commodification of of women i mean
you're renting out a woman's
womb like it's an airbnb
and paying her for the privilege to like
house
your unborn children
um it's almost like like uh
you know buying buying a space like a
storage space or something like that
renting storage space from a u-haul
facility
like you're storing old ski equipment
and a jet ski or something but instead
you're storing your children in
somebody's womb so that's the first
problem and then also it encourages
people
to treat children as an accessory and
it's very clear that this actress that's
the way she sees it where she wants to
have kids and she likes some
aspects
of the idea of having kids
but
she doesn't want to be terribly
inconvenienced by it and she doesn't
want to um she doesn't want to fully
inhabit
motherhood
she wants to stay around the fringes of
it
and only let certain parts of it in and
have to full total control over that
so she's treating the children as
accessories in her life it's kind of
like um
fashion accessories or maybe a sort of a
hobby that you could take on
and that's we we enable people to see
children that way we enable them to live
that way
and that's not good for the people and
that's certainly not good for the
children
and also there is the problem of not
of not fully inhabiting
your own life
and the roles that you play in your own
life
like if you're if you're going to be a
mother be be a mother embrace the
fullness of motherhood to the extent
that you can
which isn't to say that um
you know you need to carry children in
your room in order to be a mother you
could adopt children
and still fully be their their mothers
but then you are if you do that then you
are fully inhabiting motherhood to the
to the extent that you can within that
context
but if your intention is to conceive
children then you should inhabit that
uh so you're rejecting it's the
rejection of your children and uh of
motherhood and of yourself also in a
weird sort of way
not good just to summarize all right
let's get now to our comment sections
[Music]
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear friends
just filming right now
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
you guys know how much i love birthdays
and surprises so i really appreciate it
appreciate that
what would i oh nice
i do i do
deeply appreciate it thank you
thanks guys happy birthday man happy
birthday thank you
uh okay i've just been told there's a
there's a clip that we're gonna play
that i'm supposed to react to so
here it is
[Music]
my four-year-old son asked me mommy
who makes the twitter mob fly off the
handle with rage
who's to blame
[Music]
i told him we
[Music]
we
we
make the twitter mob fly off the handle
with rage
with rage
we
we
we
are rocking polka dots and flannel
shirts without shame without shame
without shame
[Music]
do you know our name
well do you
we're the sweet baby gang the sweet baby
gang the sweet baby gang the sweet baby
gang
[Music]
and we have a crucial message for our
sweet daddy
[Music]
hello
[Music]
for life
okay um
i don't know i i'm so uh confused right
now
like so much of the audiences i'm sure
confused
but
also deeply touched in a you know weird
way
and that's not a phrase that i use very
often and i wish i hadn't just used it
then but i did
um
that was that was i mean that was i have
to admit that was beautifully done
i don't know i don't know what else to
say about that that was that looked like
that took a lot of work and that's from
the is that that's from the spg facebook
group i believe right yeah that's what
that's who it's from
that took that looked like to me i don't
know a lot about editing but that took
that looked like it took at least you
know 30 40 minutes and uh
i do appreciate it
um as much as i'm opposed to any
recognitions of birthdays especially my
own i still will i will allow that and
i'll even say thank you to the sweet
baby gang for that
um
all right we're going to try to soldier
on from that
and we'll go here
ruth lewis says i think matt is too hard
on trump he couldn't govern great
because his administration was tied up
with phony witch hunts
for four years sorry i'm still thinking
about that a sweet baby gang tribute uh
what are we talking about here okay i
think matt is too hard on trump he
couldn't govern great because his
administration was tied up with uh phony
witch hunts for four years yeah look
i'm not interested in the excuses though
okay if you're president united states
that's true the funny witch hunts and
everything else and he had the media
against him and everybody was against
him and
there were there were things that they
were doing against trump that were quite
unprecedented no doubt about that
i don't deny any of that
um
but at the same time
okay and if we're talking about this as
just a sort of post-mortem of the trump
years
and trying to figure out why um
why it went the way that he did and why
he didn't
fulfill
ultimately
many of the promises that he made and
you want to bring up the phony witch
hunters witch hunts and so forth then
fine but if we're talking about
going forward for 2024
you know your argument for trump 2024
can't be a bunch of excuses for 2016
through 2020. you see what i'm saying
so i don't want to hear this and this is
kind of the argument i've heard from a
lot of the a lot of people that want
trump in 2024 is that well
give him another chance it's like what
no what is this what do you give them
another chance this isn't like
little league baseball or something so
set them out there to pitch another
inning it's this this is the country
and by the way if trump
could be hog-tied by phony witch-hunts
as you put it
well that's going to happen again you
think they're not going to do it again
if he gets in there it's going to be
that times 50. it's going to be what it
was the first time but way worse and so
if he's already shown that he can be
essentially disabled in his governing
by all of that then it's just going to
happen again
now you put ron desantis in there will
the same thing happen to him maybe but
the thing is we don't know yet you at
least make the argument with him that
there's we don't know how it will go so
they can have the phony witch hunts
against ron desantis will he be able to
navigate that and still govern
effectively and get and put his uh
agenda you know forward
with trump we already know how it went
and
so we know that um with ronda sanchez
there's there's a chance it might go
different so that's my argument okay
all right
devin says even if you grant all of
gender ideology shouldn't their belief
in gender fluidity alone preclude them
from allowing children to make
life-altering changes to their body
that's a really good point and that's
just but one of a million
self-contradictions in the whole
in in gender ideology in general um also
the fact that
like you're what we're told now is that
your body
has nothing to do at all with your
gender or your sex or anything else like
your body parts are totally irrelevant
we're told right
so then what
what's the point of the surgeries what's
the point of the drugs what's the point
of the of chopping the women's breasts
off and all the rest of it
because according to them
right you you can
women have penises also
there's nothing inherently male about
having a penis
so if that's the case and you identify
as a woman then why get the surgery
mutilating your genitals in the first
place
when that has nothing to do it's almost
like a separate thing now we're being
told
so it doesn't make any sense but of
course as we've discovered they nothing
to say makes any sense
um
michelle says
speaking of the uh of the drag bird song
we played yesterday wouldn't this be
more effective if a gentle delicate
female ballerina had performed this is
there something wrong with the soft
natural beauty of a young woman
well yes there is as we talked about in
the opening according to the left there
is something wrong with it and that's
why they wouldn't
have a woman do that
max says according to my research matt
is absolutely right birds sing in the
morning to mark their territory and
attract mates specifically males singing
to females they do it before dawn
because the time and lack of visibility
is optimal
as to not attract predators okay so i i
thought it was probably something like
that so i it is officially confirmed
that i know more about birds in the
audubon society and mark says hey matt
please never ever play that drag queen
bird song ever again thanks
which song you mean uh you mean this one
[Music]
[Music]
birds tell us
birds tell us that the world is changing
might make you listen to the whole thing
again that the climate is changing
there might be too much weirdness after
the spg tribute around us
in their songs
and in the songs they no longer sing
by the way autobahn society
after after posting this
they shut down their whole twitter
account in shame that's true they
actually did that
who would have ever thought that this
would be the end of the audubon society
this is how the audubon society would go
out
before this
is with drag slam poetry
people believe it's to tell each other
that they made it through the night
this information as a way of saying i'm
still here still here maybe that's why
all right that's enough of that
good you you know how that goes i can
only assume that you've left that
comment because you wanted to see the
song again because you know what happens
when you tell me things like that
right now most of the country is
experiencing a heat wave so it's a great
time to stay indoors with the ac set to
60 degrees i like to bring it down to 50
if i can and what better way to enjoy
the cool ac than to sit down and enjoy
the great content that daily wire has
put out so far this month we have the
most talked about documentary in america
what is a woman starring myself and what
is woman the book is available now so
you can stay in read the book watch the
movie we also have a true summer
blockbuster tara on the prairie star in
gina carano disney tried to cancel her
and now she's back in the gritty new
western that we've made you gotta check
out there's never been a better time to
become a daily wire member your
subscriptions uh ensure that we can
bring you more entertaining uh
entertainment more films more
documentaries that challenge the woke
narrative not only that but your
membership gives you access to an entire
library of content which includes what
is woman tear in the prairie and so much
more so head to dailywire.com
subscribe right now to join us today and
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we have the exciting opportunity
to cancel a pet food company the better
choice company makes super premium
natural pet food for millennial and gen
z pet parents
now we've already have enough fodder
here just in the opening sentence to
cancel everybody in sight but it gets
better as yahoo finance reports the very
unaptly name better choice company has
launched a new ad campaign for its halo
dog food brand and here's the marketing
pitch according to yahoo it says quote
let's face it pets are the world's best
kids that's why better choice company a
pet health and wellness company unveils
its new marketing campaign to celebrate
pet parenthood
the new halo pet campaign sets out to
validate and empower the new generation
of pet moms the campaign launches in
support of the company's new brand halo
elevate a super premium natural pet food
backed by science millennials are
delaying having children they are
however enthusiastically embracing pet
parenthood with 76 of millennials owning
a pet the new campaign from halo is
speaking to these pet moms and saying
we see you we get you we are you
now if i was a narcissist
i might think this ad campaign was made
specifically to annoy me personally
because it's got all of the elements
there
and those suspicions are not much
allayed by the actual ad itself which we
will watch now
halo makes the world's best food for the
world's best kids no not that kid this
kid you can leave this kid alone for 10
minutes and they won't destroy your
house yeah with these kids you can
actually sleep in
and shopping never ends in tears
maybe being a human parent is overrated
so if you're gonna have a kid make it a
furry one and feed them halo elevate
natural science-based nutrition for
their optimal health halo the world's
best food for the world's best kids
okay where to begin i uh i don't deny
that having kids is actually more
difficult than having a dog and we'll
get to that in a moment but first of all
dogs don't destroy your house or wake
you up
what
i find it a bit concerning that nobody
this dog food company has ever actually
met a dog apparently in fact dogs tend
to be way more destructive than children
they also can significantly be
significantly noisier and more annoying
my kids have never eaten my boots or nod
on the legs of my couch or chewed on the
carpet
my kids don't eat out of the trash
my kids don't poop on the floor usually
my kids don't wake me up in the middle
of the night barking
i don't have to take my kids outside of
the dead of winter and stand there
waiting for them to take a dump in the
grass
none of my kids have ever vomited on the
kitchen tile and then tried to eat it
dog has done that though multiple times
i came home a few days ago and someone
in the house had torn into my bookshelf
and eaten two of my favorite books
guess who did that wasn't my kids i can
tell you
now i'm starting to wonder actually what
kind of kids these people have
encountered
you know what my kids can do they can
clean up after themselves okay sure it
does take a lot of coaching and often i
have to
you know deploy various methods of
encouragement shall we say to get them
to clean up but
you can actually raise your kids to
clean up after themselves a dog will
never do that if a dog like picks up a
shoe in his mouth and walks it over to
the other side of the room right and
drops it there everybody will applaud oh
look at the dog he's so great it would
take the dog about 19 hours to clean a
whole room at that pace
my kids can do it in at least 18 hours
my kids can do other things too like
they can pour their own bowls of cereal
in the morning they can bathe themselves
in fact
they can do literally thousands of
things that the dog cannot do and will
never be able to do and as my kids get
older they'll become even more
self-sufficient while my dog will still
be barking at leaves and crapping all
over the place
but here's the main difference between
my children and the dog
they are my children
the dog is not my child he's a dog
i'm not the parent of my dog and you are
not the parent of your dog
so stop saying that you are
you are not a dog mommy do you know who
your dog's mommy is another dog there's
a dog that mated with another dog and
had a dog and that dog gave birth to
your dog
and that dog is your dog's mommy
you didn't mate with a dog and have a
dog i sure hope you didn't
okay not only are you not your pet's
parent but in fact your relationship
with with and to your pet bears no
resemblance at all to the relationship a
parent has with into their actual human
child
aside from all the many functional
differences between dogs and kids the
other major difference is that within a
human nuclear family
there's an opportunity for a loving bond
which far surpasses anything you will
ever experience with any other human
much less a mangy four-legged beast
i love my kids in a way that i could
never love an animal
i know them in a way that i could never
know an animal i was there with them
when they were born i've i've cared for
them every moment of their lives i've
gotten to know them more deeply as time
has gone on we can talk and have
conversations we can share experiences
on a much deeper and more meaningful
level then you can share any experience
with a dog
my children have brought me great joy
they uh more joy than any animal can
bring they also can make me much angrier
and more frustrated than any animal can
make me but that's only because
they are human beings they are complex
they can be
rebellious and strong-willed they're
self-aware they have their own ideas
about the world
my dog has no ideas about anything
he's an idiot and always will be
it is much more complicated to
discipline a child right
and there's more at stake
so if you fail as a parent your child
might become a monster who inflicts
unimaginable suffering on himself and
the world if you fail as a dog owner
your dog might bite the mailman or
whatever
does this mean that it's it's better to
own dogs because it's easier no
it means that owning dogs is simpler and
easier in some respects but also much
less important
there's much less potential
for greatness and for love in its
fullest and deepest form just as you
know you could you could climb a
mountain
or you could sit on your butt and watch
tv a lot less can go wrong watching tv
it's easier and takes less effort does
that mean it's better to watch tv does
that mean that you should never climb
any mountains whether literally or
metaphorically
sure if you want to live a shallow and
meaningless life
but here's the thing if you avoid the
difficult things in life
you also are avoiding the greatest joys
and most fulfilling and most meaningful
experiences that life has to offer
this is the bargain you make when you
elect to be a dog parent quote unquote
instead of a real parent
and if your goal is just to be
comfortable and live with ease then why
not get an ant farm instead of a dog why
not stick with a goldfish or a pet rock
because the further you go down the
intelligence and self-awareness ladder
the easier it is to be a parent quote
unquote of those kinds of creatures
there's also far less potential again
for love for joy for purpose for meaning
and lord willing my kids will grow older
and long after my dog dies my kids will
start having kids of their own and their
kids will have kids and eventually i
will die and as i'm laying on my
deathbed i will know and take comfort in
the fact that my children are alive
they'll be there for me in my final days
just as i was there in their
first days
i'm not going to be thinking about my
dead dog in those moments this dog i
have now will have been replaced five or
six times over by then but my legacy
will live on in my children and in
theirs
my blood will run through their veins
we'll be connected forever in this life
and the next that's parenthood
not pet ownership
now this perhaps has gotten a little too
serious for a conversation that began
with a dog food commercial but as you
may have noticed there are a few things
i hate more than when people act as
though pets are equivalent to children
they are not
and that is why the better choice dog
food company
is today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today have
a great weekend talk to you on monday
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin